1958 élections présidentielles en france
saviez-vous qu'à l'époque le chef de
l'état n'était pas élu par le peuple
mais par un collège électoral de grands
électeurs plus de 80 milles au total
composée notamment de députés de
sénateurs quatre ans plus tard le 20
septembre 1962 charles de gaulle alors
président veut changer tout ça quand ce
sera terminé
mon propre septennat ou si la mort ou la
maladie
interrompre est avant le terme
le président de la république sera
dorénavant élu au suffrage universel
son but renforcer la légitimité du
président auprès des français c'est un
coup de tonnerre politique car pour
élire le président au suffrage universel
direct il faut modifier une partie de la
constitution comment ou en organisant un
référendum auprès des français soit par
l'approbation du congrès problème le
congrès est contre ce sera donc par
référendum l'opposition politique
s'insurge elle craint que trop de
pouvoirs soit dans les mains d'un seul
homme mais si vous vous rendez compte
des dangers dramatiques que ce la
présence de l'impossibilité ensuite de
défendre vos droits vos revendications
vos libertés peut-être autrement que par
la violence si vous voulez éviter cela
alors avec nous y tenons en plus le
président charles de gaulle a décidé de
ne pas soumettre ce référendum au
parlement français ce qui est contraire
à la constitution mais du côté du
gouvernement ça n'a pas l'air d'être un
problème en 1958 quand il s'est agi
d'abolir la constitution de 1946 celle
de la quatrième république et de voter
notre actuelle constitution comment
sait-on pris par référendum sans aucun
débat parlementaire finalement malgré
plusieurs semaines de crise politique le
référendum a bien lieu où ou non le
président de la république sera-t-il élu
par tous les citoyens si la réponse est
positive elle transformera la vie
politique de l'état 28 octobre 1962 les
français se rendent aux urnes y compris
le président de la république
à la mairie de colombey les deux églises
redevenu pour un moment simple citoyen
le général de gaulle a comme tout le
monde déposer son bulletin
et les résultats tombent le soir-même
62,10 % des suffrages pour le oui
37 90 % pour le non voici donc le
général de gaulle confirmé au pouvoir à
une heure où une crise ne pouvait avoir
que de fatal conséquences c'est
historique
trois ans plus tard en 1965 c'est
l'heure de la première élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
direct avec 55,20 % des voix au second
tour charles de gaulle est réélu à la
tête de l'état face à françois
mitterrand
[Musique]